we talked about how Alexis sounds and
there are and we've done a lot of
advances in our text to speech by using
a game neural network technology for it
to sound very human-like and individual
texture of the sound the the the the
timing the tonality tone everything I
would think in terms of there's a lot of
controls in each of the places for how I
mean the speed of the boys the
prosthetic patterns the the actual
smoothness of how it sounds all of those
are factored and we do ton of listening
tests to make sure is that what
naturalness how it sounds should be very
natural how it understands requests is
also very important like and in terms of
like we have 95,000 skills or and if we
have imagined that and many of these
skills you have to remember the skilling
and say Alexa asked the tied skill to
tell me X right or now if you have to
remove the skill name that means the
discovery and the interaction is
unnatural and we are trying to solve
that by what we think of as again this
was you don't have to have the app
metaphor here these are not individual
apps right even though they're so you
cut you're not sort of opening one at a
time and interacting so yeah it should
be seamless because it's voice and when
it's voice you have to be able to
understand these requests independent of
the specificity like a skill name and to
do that what we have done is again built
a deep learning based capability where
we shot list a bunch of skills when you
say Alexa get me a car and then we
figure it out okay it's meant for a
nubile skill versus a left or based on
your preferences and then you can rank
the responses from the skill and then
choose the best response for the
customer so that's on the more natural
other examples are more natural is like
we were talking about lists for instance
and you wanna you don't wanna say Alexa
add milk likes to add eggs
Alexa had cookies no Alexa add cookies
milk and eggs and that in one shot right
so that works that helps with the
naturalness we talked about memory like
if you said you can say like so remember
I have to go to Mom's house or you may
have entered a calendar event through
your calendar that's linked to Alexa you
don't remember whether it's in my
calendar or did I tell you how to
remember something or some other
reminder right so you have to now
independent of how customers create
these events it should just say Alexa
when do I have to go to Mom's house and
it tells you when you have to go to
Mom's house that's a fascinating problem
who is that problem on so the these
people create skills uh-huh who's who's
tasked with integrating all of that
knowledge together so if the skills
become seamless is it the creators of
the skills sewer system the
infrastructure that Alexa provides
problem it's both I think the large
problem in terms of making sure your
skill quality is high we that has to be
done by our tools because it's just so
these skills just to put the context
they are built through Alexa skill
script which is a self-serve way of
building an experience on Alexa this is
like any developer in the world could go
to Alexa scales kit and build an
experience on Alexa
like if you're a Domino's you can build
a Tom know skills for instance that does
pizza ordering when you've authored that
you do want to now if people say like so
open Domino's or Alexa ask dominoes
dominoes to get a particular type of
pizza that will work but the discovery
is harder you can't just say like so get
me a pizza and then Alexa figures out
what to do that latter part is
definitely our responsibility in terms
of when the request is not fully
specific how do you figure out what's
the best skill or a service that can
fulfill the customer's request and it
can keep evolving imagine going to the
situation I said which was the night out
planning that it the goal could be more
than that individual request that came a
Pizza ordering could mean a night in
event with your kids in the house and
your so this is welcome to the world of
conversational yeah
you